La maggior parte degli uomini crede di
aver già perso prima ancora che la
partita sia iniziata. credono che
l'attrazione sia una lotteria vinta
dagli uomini con la mascella giusta, il
conto in banca giusto e le battute
giuste al momento giusto. Ma se ti
dicessi che il subconscio di una donna
ha già deciso cosa prova per te prima
ancora che tu abbia pronunciato una sola
parola.
Non dopo 10 minuti di conversazione,
non dopo che lei sa che lavoro fai, non
dopo che hai pronunciato la tua battuta
migliore, in pochi secondi,
silenziosamente,
automaticamente
e senza che lei si renda nemmeno conto
di quello che sta facendo. In questo
video ti mostrerò 20 segnali psicologici
nascosti che attraggono istantaneamente
una donna verso un uomo come una
calamita. 20 segnali che stai già
inviando oggi solo nella direzione
sbagliata, senza finta supremazia, senza
manipolazione e senza sforzo. Questo non
è un video sui proverbi. Non c'è nessuna
frase da imparare a memoria, non c'è
nessuna tecnica da praticare davanti
allo specchio finché non suona male. Si
tratta di qualcosa di più profondo del
linguaggio.
Si tratta di un sistema che è 2 milioni
di anni più antico di qualsiasi parola
tu conosca, perché prima ancora che la
loro mente ti giudichi, il loro sistema
nervoso ti ha già categorizzato e questo
giudizio è quasi impossibile da
ribaltare veloce. Per favore, mettete
tutto in pausa per un momento, metti via
il telefono, chiudi l'altra scheda.
Quello che sto per dirti nei prossimi 60
minuti è il modo più rapido per cambiare
la percezione che il mondo e soprattutto
le donne hanno di te. Stiamo parlando di
un modo per emanare un'attrazione
immediata nel momento stesso in cui lei
ti nota, non dopo averti conosciuto, nel
momento stesso in cui ti nota. E la
parte migliore è non devi sottoporti a
interventi di chirurgia estetica al
viso, vantarti del tuo conto in banca o
farti prendere dal panico per
l'attaccatura dei capelli. Dimentica il
guardaroba nuovo, dimentica
l'abbonamento in palestra che verrà
disdetto di nuovo a marzo. Dimentica
l'orologio costoso che nessuno, a parte
gli altri uomini, noterà. Niente soldi,
niente genetica e soprattutto nessun
permesso da parte di nessuno. Ciò di cui
hai bisogno sono informazioni e le
riceverai in modo completo entro i
prossimi 60 minuti. Parliamoci chiaro,
inizialmente alcune di queste cose vi
sembreranno troppo insignificanti,
troppo semplici. Penserete che sia
impossibile che una cosa del genere
possa fare la differenza. È proprio per
questo che funziona. I segnali più forti
sono sempre quelli che nessuno
percepisce consapevolmente.
Ciò che notate è l'apparenza, ciò che
non notate è la verità e il loro
cervello legge solo ciò che tu non noti.
Prima di iniziare fammi un favore, metti
un like al video e scrivi nei commenti
da dove lo stai guardando oggi. Solo la
città, solo una parola. Adoro vedere la
nostra community crescere in tutto il
mondo e onestamente questo contribuisce
a garantire che questo video raggiunga
la prossima persona che ne ha bisogno in
questo momento e non mollare fino alla
fine, perché gli ultimi quattro segnali,
il quinto atto, sono gli unici che non
puoi suonare. Sono il motivo per cui i
primi 16 funzionano per alcuni uomini. e
non per altri. La maggior parte dei
video su questo argomento si interrompe
prima di arrivare a quel punto. Noi no,
la dura verità sull'attrazione.
La maggior parte degli uomini sopra i 30
anni non scopre mai tutta la verità.
Viene detto loro di avere fiducia in se
stessi. Viene detto loro di essere se
stessi. Viene detto loro che la persona
giusta arriverà da sola. Questo non è un
consiglio, è un cerotto. Perché sii
sicuro di te, è un'istruzione senza
istruzioni. È come dire a un uomo di
diventare più alto. Descrive un
risultato senza specificare un singolo
passaggio. Ecco cosa nessuno ti ha
detto. L'aspetto fisico è solo metà
dell'opera. L'altra metà è pura biologia
e connessioni neurali. Stiamo parlando
di scorciatoie psicologiche
profondamente radicate nel subconscio
umano. Scorciatoie che il tuo cervello e
il suo utilizzano perché il pensiero
cosciente sarebbe semplicemente troppo
lento. Il tuo cervello ti elabora in
circa 13 misecondi.
13 millesimi di secondo è più veloce di
un battito di ciglia. In quellasso di
tempo non viene pensato un solo
pensiero, viene semplicemente misurato.
Le domande a cui si sta cercando di
rispondere sono: "Quest'uomo rappresenta
una minaccia? Quest'uomo è una risorsa?
Quest'uomo è al sicuro? Quest'uomo si
sente a suo agio nel proprio corpo? E
tutto ciò che accade dopo, la
conversazione, l'umorismo, le storie,
viene filtrato attraverso il risultato
di questa misurazione. Inoltre, 12 anni
di lavoro con gli uomini per aiutarli a
sviluppare il carisma, ho notato una
cosa ripetutamente.
che padroneggiate questi segnali, le
donne giureranno che siete diventati più
attraenti da un giorno all'altro, anche
se fisicamente non è cambiato nulla nel
vostro corpo. Nemmeno 1 kg in meno,
nemmeno un capello in più, nemmeno €1 in
più. E ora la domanda che giustamente vi
state ponendo è se tutto ciò è così
fondamentale, perché nessuno ve l'ha mai
spiegato? Ci sono tre motivi e tutti e
tre sono spiacevoli. Il primo motivo,
gli uomini che inviano naturalmente
questi segnali non si rendono nemmeno
conto di farlo. Chiedete al ragazzo
della scena di cui sto per parlare di
descrivere cosa fa diverso. Vi
risponderà: "Non lo so, sono solo me
stesso, non mente". Non riesce a vedere
il proprio comportamento, proprio come
voi, non riuscite a vedere il vostro. Il
migliore insegnante non è quasi mai
quello dotato di un talento naturale. Il
secondo motivo, le donne non possono
dirtelo, non per cattiveria, ma perché
la percezione di cui stiamo parlando
opera al di sotto del livello del
linguaggio. Se chiedi a una donna cosa
trova attraente, otterrai una risposta
onesta sulle sue preferenze consapevoli.
otterrai una risposta su un sistema che
si attiva 13 misecondi dopo il primo
sguardo. Lei non ha accesso a quel
sistema, nessuno ce l'ha. Il terzo
motivo, non vende bene. Un intero
settore prospera convincendoti che ti
manca qualcosa che si può comprare, un
prodotto, un programma, una
trasformazione.
Il tuo atteggiamento è sbagliato e lo
correggerai da solo in tre settimane. È
un pessimo modello di business. È vero
solo per pura coincidenza. Ecco perché
si sentono sempre gli stessi due
consigli. Abbi fiducia in te stesso e
lavora su te stesso. Entrambi sono veri,
entrambi sono inutili. È come dire a un
uomo che non sa nuotare di limitarsi a
galleggiare. Qui facciamo le cose in
modo diverso. Parliamo di meccanica.
Conosci l'immagine? Un ragazzo
dall'aspetto assolutamente nella media
sta parlando con una donna splendida.
Non è alto, non è vestito
particolarmente bene, non dice nulla che
tu non avresti potuto dire tu stesso.
Ride, gioca con i capelli, si sporge in
avanti e intanto tu resti lì in disparte
con una carriera migliore, con abiti più
costosi, con storie più interessanti che
nessuno sentirà perché nessuno te le
chiederà. Nell'ultima mezz'ora hai
pensato di intervenire tre volte. Tre
volte hai formulato la frase perfetta e
tre volte l'occasione si è chiusa prima
che potessi pronunciarla. E a un certo
punto ti chiedi cosha lui che io non ho?
Ti dirò cosa ha. Lui non ha nulla che tu
non abbia già. Semplicemente invia
segnali diversi. Il suo corpo dice
qualcosa che il tuo non dice. Le sue
pause suggeriscono qualcosa che le tue
non dicono. Il suo passo rivela una
sicurezza che a te manca. Non ha vinto
perché era più bravo, ha vinto perché
era leggibile. Questa è proprio la buona
notizia di tutto questo video. La
leggibilità è un'abilità, non un tratto
caratteriale, non un dono. Non è
genetica, non è magia. Sono segnali. È
possibile apprendere i segnali. Partiamo
dai quattro segnali che vengono decisi
prima ancora che tu apra bocca. Atto
primo, la presenza, ciò che comunica
prima ancora che tu parli. C'è un
momento che nessun uomo può controllare
e quasi tutti gli uomini lo perdono. Il
momento tra "Ti ha visto e hai detto
qualcosa per te sono 2 secondi di pausa.
Per il loro sistema nervoso è l'intero
colloquio di lavoro. Tutto ciò che segue
non è altro che conferma o correzione di
un giudizio già espresso. I quattro
segnali di quest'atto determinano questo
momento, non ti costano nulla, non
richiedono alcun talento e funzionano
mentre tu sei in silenzio. Segnale uno,
l'effetto alone le fondamenta dei 5
secondi. La maggior parte degli uomini
entra in una stanza come se dovesse
scusarsi per lo spazio che occupa.
Spalle si incurvano in avanti, il mento
si abbassa, gli occhi scrutano il
terreno in cerca di un posto sicuro. Il
corpo si rannicchia istintivamente,
inconsciamente, per cortesia. E proprio
questa cortesia viene interpretata come
un segno di rango, psicologia. Il
cervello umano è intrinsecamente
efficiente quando individua una singola
caratteristica di alta qualità.
presume automaticamente che siano
presenti anche una dozzina di altre
qualità positive. Questo è l'effetto
alone. Un punto di forza visibile
proietta un alone attorno a tutto il
resto. La tua intelligenza, la tua
competenza, la tua affidabilità.
semplicemente presuppone qualità che non
può assolutamente valutare in 5 secondi.
La biologia, quando si sta in piedi con
il petto aperto e il mento sollevato, il
livello di cortisolo, l'ormone dello
stress si abbassa e la propria presenza
si espande. Il corpo percepisce la
postura prima ancora che la mente lo
faccia.
Non si tratta di fingere calma, ma di
crearla chimicamente. L'esecuzione entra
in una stanza come se fosse tua, spalle
indietro, colonna vertebrale dritta,
sterno sollevato di 2 cm e poi, questa è
la parte che quasi tutti saltano, resta
fermo sulla porta per 3 secondi prima di
iniziare a camminare. Non sto cercando,
non sto scansionando,
semplicemente resto immobile. Il
risultato? Il tuo cervello ti etichetta
immediatamente come una persona di alto
livello, capace e con i piedi per terra.
E l'uomo che riesce a stare fermo senza
sentirsi a disagio comunica qualcosa che
nessun abito elegante può eguagliare.
Chi ha fretta di arrivare non è ancora
arrivato. Segnale numero due. La regola
del secondo secondo per il contatto
visivo. La maggior parte degli uomini o
fissa con sguardo predatorio oppure
distoglie lo sguardo per la vergogna
come uno scolaretto colto inflagrante.
Entrambe queste affermazioni denotano
una scarsa autostima. Una disse: "Voglio
qualcosa da te e non posso nasconderlo".
L'altra dice non ho il diritto di
guardarti. Esiste una terza via e quasi
nessuno la conosce. Psicologia. Nel
regno animale il contatto visivo è un
simbolo di status. Chi distoglie lo
sguardo per primo ha risposto alla
domanda sul rango, ma ed è fondamentale,
chi non distoglie mai lo sguardo non ha
posto la domanda, ma ha solo iniziato
una lotta. La sovranità non sta nel
conquistare il contatto visivo, ma nel
sapere quando interromperlo. La mossa.
Quando i vostri sguardi si incrociano,
manteneteli fissi per esattamente un
secondo. Non contate mentalmente. Un
secondo è come un respiro profondo.
Fate un cenno minimo, appena
percettibile o un mezzo sorriso e poi
siate i primi a distogliere lo sguardo
lentamente,
non bruscamente, come se avessi
finalmente trovato ciò che cercavi. Ciò
che lei sente inconsciamente è: "Ti
vedo, non mi sento intimidita, ma non ho
nemmeno un disperato bisogno della tua
attenzione. L'effetto crea
immediatamente un piccolo colpo di scena
nella sua mente perché hai aperto una
connessione e poi l'hai chiusa senza
dare spiegazioni. Il suo cervello
detesta i modelli incompiuti. Ci tornerà
su. Non stasera forse, ma ci tornerà. Lo
sguardo che restituisci è più importante
dello sguardo che ricevi. Segnale 3. La
frequenza di lampeggio lenta. Può
sembrare strano, ma è estremamente
potente. Gli animali da preda nervosi e
ansiosi sbattono le palpebre rapidamente
come un colibrì. Il loro sistema nervoso
scansiona costantemente l'ambiente alla
ricerca di pericoli e la palpebra è la
parte più visibile di questa scansione.
E sì, questo vale anche per gli uomini
che conversano. La biologia, i mammiferi
di alto rango e dominanti sbattono le
palpebre più lentamente perché si
sentono al sicuro nel loro ambiente. La
frequenza di ammiccamento è direttamente
collegata al sistema nervoso autonomo,
aumenta in condizioni di stress e
diminuisce quando è controllata. Non si
può dire direttamente al sistema nervoso
di calmarsi, ma lo si può influenzare
indirettamente attraverso le palpebre.
L'esercizio,
mentre l'ascolti, fai in modo che le tue
palpebre si alzino e si abbassino solo
una frazione di secondo, più lentamente
del normale, non in modo teatrale, non
assonnato. Una frazione di secondo più
lenta, così piccola, che nessuno
potrebbe percepirla consapevolmente.
Non esercitarti davanti allo specchio.
esercitati mentre guardi la TV, guidi o
parli con il fornaio dovrebbe diventare
uno stato d'animo, non una tecnica. Il
risultato appare controllata e calma.
Noterai spesso che le sue pupille si
dilatano mentre si rilassa
inconsciamente in tua presenza. Un
sistema nervoso calmo è contagioso. Il
suo corpo rispecchia il tuo prima ancora
che la sua mente decida se farlo o meno.
Ed è proprio questo il punto che quasi
nessuno capisce. L'attrazione non è ciò
che tu susciti in lei. L'attrazione è
ciò che lei prova dentro di sé in tua
presenza. Segnale numero 4. Il
linguaggio del corpo che dice "Non ho
fretta". Un uomo che affretta appare
bisognoso. Se ti muovi troppo
velocemente, controlli continuamente il
telefono o snoccioli frasi come se fossi
sotto pressione, stai segnalando che non
sei pienamente presente e la presenza è
l'unica moneta che conta in questo
momento. Psicologia. La fretta è un
segnale di status, ma quello sbagliato.
Chi appare di fretta comunica che i
propri impegni sono dettati dagli altri.
Chi si muove lentamente comunica di
avere il controllo del proprio tempo. Le
persone di potere raramente appaiono di
fretta. Non è una posa, è una
conseguenza. L'aggiustamento.
Rallenta i tuoi movimenti di circa il
20%.
Quando bevi un sorso d'acqua, fallo
lentamente. Quando giri la testa, fallo
con movimenti fluidi. Quando appoggi il
bicchiere appoggialo, non lasciarlo
cadere. È la versione più difficile di
questo esercizio. Se il tuo telefono
vibra in sua presenza, non guardarlo
nemmeno una volta. l'effetto rimarrai
sorpreso dalla rapidità con cui le
persone adattano il loro ritmo al tuo.
Chi è più lento degli altri, detta il
ritmo, la presenza è il dono più
prezioso che si possa fare a una donna
ed è anche il più raro. Riceve
attenzioni ogni giorno, ma quasi mai
riceve attenzioni esclusive. La
differenza tra i due sta nella
differenza tra ciò che viene notato e
ciò che viene ricordato. Questi sono i
quattro segnali che lei percepisce prima
che tu parli.
Se a partire da domani non cambiate
altro che la postura, il ritmo e la
frequenza del battito delle palpebre,
noterete entro due settimane che le
conversazioni inizieranno in modo
diverso, non migliore, ma diverso. Le
persone vi interromperanno meno spesso,
aspetteranno quando farete una pausa, ma
esiste un canale che funziona ancora più
velocemente del tuo corpo, un canale che
usi fin dall'infanzia e che quasi nessun
uomo ha mai allenato consapevolmente.
E se questo canale trasmette un
messaggio sbagliato, nessun
atteggiamento al mondo potrà salvarlo.
Secondo, la voce, ciò che sente prima di
ascoltare. Esiste un esperimento che è
stato condotto ripetutamente in varie
forme nella ricerca sulla comunicazione.
Alle persone vengono fatte ascoltare
registrazioni di conversazioni, ma
filtrate. Le parole diventano
incomprensibili. Rimangono solo la
melodia, il ritmo e il timbro. Nessun
contenuto, solo suono. Eppure gli
ascoltatori riescono ancora a dire con
sorprendente precisione chi aveva il
controllo in quella conversazione, chi
pressioni, chi si scusava senza dirlo
esplicitamente.
Lei non sente quello che dici, sente la
sicurezza di sé, dell'uomo che lo dice.
Nessuno dei seguenti quattro segnali ha
a che fare con la scelta delle parole.
Nessuno di essi richiede che tu diventi
più interessante. Segnale 5. Il
rallentamento del 10%.
Un uomo spaventato parla in fretta. Lo
fa perché teme di essere interrotto o
perché crede che il tempo stia per
scadere o perché in fondo sa già che
quello che sta dicendo non è abbastanza
buono e vuole arrivare il più
velocemente possibile alla frase
successiva che potrebbe effettivamente
essere abbastanza buona.
E lei ascolta ognuna di queste ragioni,
non consapevolmente,
ma pienamente. La biologia, una voce
calma, è indice di un sistema nervoso
regolato. Sotto stress, la laringe si
restringe, la respirazione diventa
superficiale, la voce si alza e si
assottiglia. Quando si parla più
lentamente, ci si costringe
automaticamente a respirare più
profondamente e una respirazione più
profonda abbassa di per sé il tono della
voce. Non è necessario abbassare il tono
della voce, basta smettere di cercare di
farlo. L'abitudine, parla il 10% più
lentamente di quanto ti sembri naturale.
Solo il 10% è una velocità così bassa
che nessuno la percepirà come lentezza e
così alta che tutti la percepiranno come
calma. Ecco un secondo consiglio.
Espirate prima di iniziare a parlare.
Non inspirate, ma espirate. Quasi tutti
gli uomini iniziano una frase con il
diaframma contratto e teso. Chi invece
inizia espirando suona subito teso e
concentrato. L'effetto conferisce alla
voce una qualità più profonda e ricca.
Le donne si fidano istintivamente di più
di un uomo quando parla lentamente, non
perché la lentezza suoni intelligente,
ma perché segnala che non ha paura di
perdere l'attenzione del pubblico. Chi
ha fretta di essere ascoltato non è mai
stato veramente ascoltato. Segnale 6. Il
potere del silenzio. Molti uomini
pensano di dover riempire ogni spazio
vuoto nella conversazione.
Credono che una pausa significhi la fine
dell'interazione.
Quindi parlano di più, spiegano di più,
esagerano e iniziano a recitare.
Aggiungono un poscritto esplicativo a
un'affermazione che era già completa. il
dono della propria battuta prima ancora
di aver verificato se funziona. Ma più
ti esibisci, meno potere hai. La
consapevolezza.
Il silenzio è imbarazzante solo se si è
nervosi. Non ha una qualità intrinseca.
È uno spazio vuoto e ognuno nella stanza
lo riempie con ciò che porta con sé. Se
si è radicati, il silenzio crea tensione
e la tensione crea attrazione. Il
cambiamento sopporta una pausa senza
cercare di riempirla, pronuncia la tua
frase e poi non dire più nulla. La prova
definitiva. Se hai detto qualcosa che
era un complimento, un invito o una
proposta rischiosa, rimani in silenzio
dopo. In quel preciso istante, ogni
fibra del tuo essere vorrebbe
minimizzare l'accaduto.
Era solo un pensiero. Non sei obbligato,
tanto non ha importanza. Ciascuna di
queste qualifiche annulla il segnale
appena inviato. Cosa comunica? controllo
emotivo, una delle qualità più attraenti
di un uomo, perché chi sa sopportare il
silenzio ha dimostrato di saper gestire
anche i propri tormenti interiori.
E una donna che percepisce che un uomo
sa gestire i propri tormenti, percepisce
anche che lui saprebbe gestire i suoi.
Questa non è comunicazione, questa è una
promessa. Segnale 7. La micropausa
durante le domande. Se ti fa una
domanda, non rispondere subito. La
risposta rapida ti sembra utile. Per lei
sembra preparata e la preparazione è
nemica dell'attrazione perché tradisce
un bisogno di attenzione. Tu avevi già
la risposta pronta perché stavi
aspettando la domanda, la mossa. Aspetta
mezzo battito di cuore, sostieni il suo
sguardo per un secondo e poi rispondi:
"Mezzo battito cardiaco, niente di più.
Così breve che lei non lo interpreta
come esitazione, così lungo che il suo
sistema nervoso lo interpreta come peso.
La psicologia che si cela dietro. Questo
breve momento di silenzio di non hai
paura della tensione e che rifletti
prima di agire. è segno di maturità
emotiva e ha un secondo effetto più
sottile. Accresce il valore della sua
domanda. Una domanda che induce alla
riflessione era chiaramente una buona
domanda. Senza farle un solo
complimento. Le hai fatto il più grande
complimento che ci sia. L'hai presa sul
serio. L'effetto le donne raramente
ricordano cosa ha risposto un uomo.
Ricordano invece la sensazione provata
nel fargli una domanda. Chi risponde
immediatamente ha ascoltato per poter
rispondere. Chi aspetta un attimo ha
ascoltato per capire. La differenza dura
mezzo secondo e si protrae per anni.
Segnale 8. Il set termina verso il
basso. Questo è il segnale più
invisibile dell'intero video e al tempo
stesso uno dei più significativi.
Prestate attenzione a come la maggior
parte degli uomini termina le frasi. Il
tono si alza leggermente alla fine senza
che nessuno se ne accorga.
Un'affermazione si trasforma in una
domanda: "Lavoro nel settore edile? Era
un ristorante piuttosto buono?
Non hanno chiesto nulla, ma la loro
melodia chiedeva conferma. Psicologia,
un'intonazione ascendente alla fine di
una frase è un segnale universale di
sottomissione in quasi tutte le lingue
umane. Significa va bene così o ancora
ragione, sei d'accordo con me? Chi parla
in questo modo chiede approvazione dopo
ogni frase, un'approvazione di cui non
ha bisogno. La correzione abbassa
leggermente il tono della voce alla fine
della frase, termina la frase con un
accento discendente e poi la seconda
parte senza la quale la prima è
inefficace, lasciala così com'è. Niente
o niente sai, niente più o meno comunque
2 gradi in meno. Punto. Fine della
storia. Il risultato, la stessa frase,
le stesse parole, la stessa persona e
improvvisamente suona come
un'informazione
anziché come una richiesta. Registra un
messaggio vocale e ascoltalo. Non
prestare attenzione al contenuto.
Concentrati solo sulle ultime due parole
di ogni frase. Questo è l'esercizio più
imbarazzante del video, ma anche il più
veloce. Un uomo che porta a termine le
sue frasi è un uomo che porta a termine
le sue decisioni. Stato attuale, otto
segnali, quattro per il corpo, quattro
per la voce. Se sei arrivato fin qui,
hai già imparato più cose
sull'attrazione non verbale di quante ne
imparino la maggior parte degli uomini
in tutta la loro vita e non hai imparato
nulla che richieda alcun tipo di
coraggio. Ora la cosa si fa più
interessante perché i prossimi quattro
segnali non riguardano più il tuo
comportamento, ma il modo in cui
rivendichi spazio. E lo spazio è la più
antica valuta di status che esista, più
antica del linguaggio, più antica del
denaro, antica quanto il territorio
stesso. Il segnale numero 11 è quello
con cui la maggior parte degli uomini ha
più difficoltà, non perché sia
difficile, ma perché sembra sbagliato. E
prima di proseguire, una breve premessa,
solo una piccola minoranza riesce a
resistere così a lungo. La maggior parte
degli spettatori se n'è andata da tempo,
non perché non sia interessata
all'argomento, ma perché nel momento in
cui diventa concreto smette di essere
divertente e inizia a sembrare un
lavoro. Sei ancora qui? Già questo è un
segno. Ti è stato utile anche un solo
spunto finora? Allora metti un like, ti
ci vuole solo un secondo e può fare la
differenza tra questo video e quello di
qualcun altro che si trova nella tua
stessa situazione di un anno fa.
Scrivete nei commenti quale dei primi
otto segnali vi ha colpito di più. Basta
il numero, l'ho letto davvero e baserò i
prossimi video su questo. Va bene,
passiamo alla stanza. Atto terzo, lo
spazio. Come rivendicare un territorio
senza sfrattare nessuno. C'è un motivo
per cui si usa l'espressione riempie una
stanza e non riempie una conversazione.
Molto prima che gli esseri umani
avessero il linguaggio avevano il
concetto di distanza. Chi stava a che
distanza da chi? Chi si voltava verso
chi? Chi voltava le spalle a chi? Queste
erano tutte le informazioni sociali di
un gruppo. Questo software è ancora in
esecuzione, non è mai stato
disinstallato
e corre più veloce di qualsiasi parola
tu possa pronunciare. Gli uomini
commettono la maggior parte degli errori
con i prossimi quattro segnali perché
fanno l'opposto di ciò che è stato loro
insegnato come buona educazione. Segnale
9. Il triangolo aperto. Il linguaggio
del corpo non riguarda solo le mani,
riguarda l'intero orientamento nello
spazio. Molti uomini commettono lo
stesso errore quando parlano con una
donna, le stanno di fronte. Entrambi i
piedi sono rivolti verso di lei,
entrambe le spalle sono rivolte verso di
lei. Tutto il loro corpo dice: "Tu sei
il bersaglio". dovrebbe essere un gesto
di apprezzamento. Viene percepito come
una pressione. Psicologia nel
comportamento dei mammiferi una postura
completamente frontale è un
atteggiamento di confronto. Segnala o
lotta o corteggiamento.
Ed entrambe creano in lei una leggera
ineffabile tensione. non sa spiegare
perché la conversazione le sembri tesa,
semplicemente la percepisce come tale.
La modifica inclina i piedi e i fianchi
di circa 30° lateralmente, creando un
triangolo aperto. La parte superiore del
corpo può essere rivolta verso il
triangolo, ma non la base. Sei in piedi
accanto al mondo, non contro di esso. E
quando sei seduto, appoggiati
leggermente allo schienale, non in
avanti. Il risultato? Questo le dà lo
spazio psicologico per respirare e la
spinge ad avvicinarsi a te di sua
spontanea volontà, perché le persone non
occupano spazi già pieni, ma spazi che
sono stati lasciati liberi. Ecco la
parte che spiega quasi tutto
sull'attrazione.
Ogni passo che lei fa verso di te cambia
qualcosa in lei, non in te. Chi crea
spazio vince il movimento. Segnale 10.
Il punto di ancoraggio, i piedi che non
vagano. Osservate i piedi di un uomo
nervoso, non stanno mai fermi. Sposta il
peso da sinistra a destra, fa un mezzo
passo avanti e poi di nuovo indietro.
Oscilla quasi impercettibilmente la
caviglia. Lui stesso non se ne accorge,
ma appare fugace nella visione
periferica di ogni persona presente
nella stanza. Biologia. Lo spostamento
del peso è un segnale di preparazione
alla fuga. Il corpo mantiene le gambe in
movimento perché una parte del sistema
nervoso non ha ancora valutato la
situazione come si cura e vuole
mantenere aperta la possibilità di
fuggire immediatamente.
Non si tratta di una metafora. Questo è
letteralmente lo scopo di questo
movimento. Esercizio. Stando in piedi,
scegliete un punto di ancoraggio.
Distribuite il peso in modo uniforme su
entrambi i piedi, distanziandoli circa
quanto la larghezza delle anche e
mantenetelo in quella posizione. Se
volete muovervi fatelo intenzionalmente,
fate un passo completo verso una nuova
posizione, quindi ancoratevi di nuovo.
Niente mezze misure, non si può cambiare
posizione. O si sta fermi o si va
avanti. l'effetto la quiete viene
percepita come sicurezza
e nel sistema nervoso di una donna la
sicurezza non è sinonimo di forza, anzi
è più preziosa della forza. Può
rilassarsi accanto a un uomo il cui
corpo non pulsa. Molti uomini, quando lo
fanno consapevolmente per la prima volta
vivono un'esperienza particolare. Le
persone nella stanza iniziano a
orientarsi intorno a loro. Le
conversazioni si concentrano attorno a
chi rimane immobile. Un uomo che non va
diventa un punto fisso e i punti fissi
non si cercano, si trovano. Segnale 11.
Attenzione ritardata, prima gli occhi,
poi la testa. In questi 60 minuti nessun
altro momento è più difficile per gli
uomini di questo e dura mezzo secondo
quando viene pronunciato il tuo nome,
quando qualcuno alle tue spalle ride,
quando si apre una porta, cosa fa la tua
testa? Gira su se stessa immediatamente,
completamente verso la fonte del
problema. Ogni volta che muovi
bruscamente la testa, comunichi a tutti
nella stanza chi sta reagendo a chi.
Psicologia. La velocità di reazione è un
mezzo per assegnare un rango sociale. In
ogni gruppo sociale, sia negli esseri
umani che nei primati, l'individuo di
rango inferiore si gira immediatamente
verso il suono. L'individuo di rango
superiore si gira per ultimo o non si
gira affatto, non per arroganza, ma
perché il suo sistema nervoso non
classifica l'ambiente come qualcosa di
sorprendente.
la correzione, prima muovi gli occhi,
poi la testa. Quando ti giri verso
qualcuno, gira la testa una frazione di
secondo più tardi e una frazione di
secondo più lentamente di quanto ti
suggerirebbe il riflesso. Mezzo battito
cardiaco, la stessa unità del segnale 7.
E se siete impegnati in una
conversazione e qualcuno vi chiama per
nome, finite la frase prima di voltarvi.
Perché sembra sbagliato, perché sembra
scortese. Non lo è. Sembra scortese a te
perché sei abituato a dimostrare la tua
disponibilità. Agli altri invece appare
come compostezza.
Il risultato: lei capisce che la tua
attenzione non è gratuita e tutto ciò
che non è gratuito acquisisce valore.
L'attenzione che tutti ricevono non è un
dono per nessuno. Segnale 12. La mancata
risposta. Ad un certo punto di ogni
conversazione c'è una prova. Di solito è
sottile, una leggera provocazione, un
po' di presa in giro, una domanda un po'
troppo diretta.
un commento sulla tua età, sulla tua
camicia, sul tuo lavoro, un breve
silenzio in attesa di una reazione.
Quasi nessuno supera questa prova perché
quasi nessuno si rende conto che si
tratta di una prova. La psicologia lo
spiega così. Le persone mettono
inconsciamente alla prova la stabilità
emotiva di un'altra persona prima di
aprirsi. Non lo fanno per ferirti, ma
perché vogliono capire come reagisci
sotto una pressione minima, perché
questo ti permette di prevedere come
reagirai sotto una pressione maggiore.
Un piccolo stimolo per vedere se le
difese reggono. La mossa giusta non
giustificarti,
non dare spiegazioni, non esagerare.
Sostieni il suo sguardo, accenna un
mezzo sorriso e rispondi brevemente o
non rispondere affatto. L'errore non è
mai la soluzione. L'errore sta nella
quantità. Tre frasi in difesa sono una
sconfitta. Cinque parole pronunciate con
calma sono una vittoria. L'effetto non
appena una provocazione fallisce,
qualcosa nella stanza cambia. Lei ha
imparato. Quest'uomo non dipende dal suo
umore e un uomo che non dipende dal suo
umore è un uomo al quale può mostrare i
suoi veri sentimenti. Questo è l'inizio
dell'intimità, non della simpatia, ma
della sicurezza. Chi non reagisce non ha
bisogno di essere controllato e chi non
ha bisogno di essere controllato può
essere apprezzato. 12 segnali. E ora
arriviamo all'ambito in cui gli uomini
credono di avere meno controllo, ma in
realtà ne hanno di più. Il tuo viso
trasmette emozioni in ogni istante in
cui sei sveglio. Non puoi spegnerlo, non
puoi nasconderlo e la maggior parte
degli uomini non ha mai saputo cosa stia
realmente dicendo il proprio viso quando
è a riposo. Per la maggior parte delle
persone significa stanchezza. tensione o
distacco, questo non è vero per nessuno
di loro. Atto quarto. Il volto, il
canale che nessuno controlla. C'è una
verità scomoda riguardo al tuo viso. Non
l'hai mai visto, non davvero. L'hai
visto allo specchio, ma allo specchio
stai guardando il tuo stesso volto e un
volto che guarda se stesso non è mai il
volto che vedono gli altri. è
concentrato, giudicante, leggermente
teso. Non hai mai visto il volto che lei
vede. Di seguito vengono corretti i
quattro messaggi errati più comuni che
il viso di un uomo di oltre 30 anni
trasmette senza che lui se ne renda
conto. Segnale 13. Il lampo del
sopracciglio. Un quinto di secondo.
Esiste un gesto umano che si manifesta
in ogni cultura studiata al mondo e che
nessun essere umano ha appreso
consapevolmente.
Quando riconosciamo qualcuno che ci
piace, le nostre sopracciglia si alzano
per circa un quinto di secondo
automaticamente,
involontariamente,
troppo velocemente per essere percepito
consapevolmente.
Eppure ogni cervello lo registra in modo
affidabile. È il più antico gesto di
saluto esistente.
Biologia. Il gesto di alzare le
sopracciglia segnala riconoscimento
senza minaccia. In una frazione di
secondo dice: "Ti vedo, ti considero una
persona benvenuta e non ho intenzione di
nascondermi." Le persone che compiono
questo gesto vengono in media percepite
come significativamente più cordiali,
mentre quelle che lo sopprimono appaiono
distaccate o arroganti, perché gli
uomini perdono la calma, il nervosismo
la sopprime. Quando sono tesi gli uomini
tengono la fronte immobile. Inoltre
molti hanno sviluppato l'abitudine di
mantenere consapevolmente un'espressione
neutra perché credono che trasmetta
sicurezza. In realtà appare fredda la
tecnica. Quando il tuo sguardo incontra
il suo, solleva leggermente le
sopracciglia. Non alzarle del tutto, non
sorprenderla. Lasciale rilassate è più
un gesto di apertura che un vero e
proprio sollevamento. Il risultato
calore prima ancora che venga
pronunciata una parola. E il calore è
proprio l'aspetto che quasi tutti i
video sull'attrazione omettono. Perché
non suona come forza. Lo status apre le
porte. È il calore umano che decide se
qualcuno può varcarle. Segnale 14. Il
sorriso in tasca, gli occhi di Cluny. Un
sorriso ampio e forzato spesso viene
percepito come un segno di bisogno. È
troppo da offrire tutto in una volta. È
come dire "Per favore, apprezzatemi". E
più ampio è il sorriso, più chiaramente
lo dice un uomo, il cui sorriso è
immediatamente al massimo della sua
potenza. ha speso tutto il suo capitale
nel primo secondo. La psicologia lo
spiega così. Esistono due tipi di
sorriso e ogni cervello è in grado di
distinguerli. Il sorriso sociale muove
solo la bocca. Il sorriso genuino muove
l'anello muscolare intorno agli occhi e
questo muscolo è quasi impossibile da
controllare consapevolmente.
È proprio per questo che è un segnale
così affidabile, non può essere
facilmente simulato ed è per questo che
si crede che lo sia. La tecnica tieni la
bocca rilassata o con un accenno di
sorriso, quel sorriso nascosto che porti
sempre con te, ma che non mostri. Allo
stesso tempo lascia che gli angoli dei
tuoi occhi si incurvino in un sorriso
naturale, il trucco per farlo sembrare
reale. Quando guardi, non pensare,
sorridi, pensa, mi piace. Il muscolo
segue il pensiero, non il comando.
Questo è il look di George Cloney. 20%
bocca, 80% occhi. L'effetto trasmette
calore, autenticità e indica che hai la
situazione sotto controllo e ha una
qualità che un ampio sorriso non ha mai.
Permette di intensificare la
discussione. Chi inizia in piccolo ha
ancora qualcosa da dare. Chi inizia in
grande non deve far altro che ripetere
l'impresa. Segnale 15. Il sorriso
ritardato. La maggior parte degli uomini
sorride troppo presto. Entrano in una
stanza già sorridenti, si avvicinano
sorridendo. Il sorriso è già lì prima
che ci sia qualcuno e perciò non
appartiene a nessuno. Un sorriso che
c'era già prima che lei arrivasse non è
un complimento, è un atteggiamento
fondamentale.
La psicologia ci insegna che un sorriso
ha significato solo se è una reazione.
La tempistica è fondamentale.
Un sorriso che appare prima del contatto
visivo dice: "Sorrido a tutti".
Un sorriso che appare mezzo secondo dopo
il contatto visivo dice qualcosa di
completamente diverso. Ti ho guardato e
poi sei diventato il motivo del mio
sguardo. È la stessa espressione
facciale. L'ordine lo rende un regalo.
La mossa, un'espressione neutra e calma,
contatto visivo, mezzo secondo di
silenzio. Poi il sorriso si diffonde
lentamente dagli occhi verso l'esterno.
La lentezza è fondamentale in questo
caso. Un sorriso che scatta come un
interruttore sembra meccanico. Un
sorriso che si diffonde come calore
sembra involontario.
Ed è proprio per questo che si crede che
sia involontario il risultato. Lei si
sente la causa e questa è una delle
esperienze più intense che una persona
possa vivere in presenza di un'altra.
Sentire di aver innescato in qualcuno
qualcosa che non aveva previsto. Nessuno
merita un sorriso che tutti ricevono.
Segnale 16. Distruggi l'illusione dei
riflettori. Molti uomini sono
ossessionati dai capelli grigi o da
qualche chilo di troppo. Rimangono in
piedi nella stanza. in continua
autoanalisi. La camicia è troppo larga
sulla pancia, si vede la loro fronte,
hanno riso troppo forte, credono di
essere osservati e in effetti lo sono,
ma dalla persona sbagliata. Il segreto
nessuno studia i tuoi errori con la
stessa meticolosità con cui li analizzi
tu. Le persone tendono a sovrastimare
sistematicamente quanto gli altri le
notino. Il motivo è semplice. Ognuno è
al centro della propria percezione e
presume automaticamente di esserlo anche
nella percezione altrui. Questo è
l'effetto riflettore. Il riflettore
esiste, solo che non è puntato su di te.
Ognuno è concentrato sulla propria
immagine. Il cambiamento. Nel momento in
cui smetti di tirarti la maglietta, di
nascondere la testa o di correggere la
postura, questi difetti diventano quasi
invisibili, perché ciò che lei
percepisce non è mai il difetto in sé, è
la tua reazione ad esso. Una pancia che
viene portata via scompare. Una pancia
che viene nascosta diventa l'argomento
principale della conversazione perché
sei tu stesso ad averlo reso tale.
L'esercizio per una settimana segui una
sola regola, niente correzioni in
presenza di altri. Non tirarti la
maglietta, non passarti le mani tra i
capelli, non aggiustare la postura se ti
accorgi di essere osservato. Il
risultato.
Coloro che possiedono una forte presenza
fisica appaiono più maturi anziché
anziani. Il grigio non è un problema. Il
grigio che si scusa lo è. 16 segnali. Se
metterai in pratica tutti questi
principi, verrai percepito in modo
diverso in ogni ambiente rispetto a
oggi. Non è un'esagerazione, è
semplicemente una questione di
meccanica. Ma ora arriva la parte per
cui vi ho chiesto di rimanere fino alla
fine, perché ci sono uomini che eseguono
tutti e 16 i segnali tecnicamente in
modo corretto, eppure non succede nulla.
Sembra tutto preparato, sembra vuoto. Le
donne percepiscono in pochi minuti che
qualcosa non va, ma non riescono mai a
capire esattamente cosa. Il motivo
risiede negli ultimi quattro segnali.
Sono gli unici che non possono essere
riprodotti e sono loro la ragione per
cui tutto ciò che li precede funziona o
non funziona. Atto quinto. Lo stato
interiore, il segnale dietro tutti i
segnali. A questo punto devo dirvi
qualcosa che sembra contraddire tutto
ciò che è accaduto finora nel video. I
16 segnali che avete appena appreso non
sono cause, bensì sintomi. Sono ciò che
un uomo fa automaticamente in un certo
stato interiore. Ed è per questo che
funzionano in entrambi i sensi. Puoi
raggiungere quello stato attraverso il
corpo. Questo è il modo più veloce ed è
reale. Oppure puoi raggiungere quello
stato direttamente. Questo è il modo più
lento e dopo non devi più pensare a
nessuna tecnica. Gli ultimi quattro
segnali indicano il percorso lento. Non
si possono simulare, si può fingere un
atteggiamento,
non si può fingere uno stato d'animo
interiore, non per più di una ventina di
minuti. E le donne quasi sempre si
accorgono della pausa. Ecco perché
vengono per ultimi, non perché siano i
più pesanti, ma perché sono ciò che
permette agli altri 16 di sostenere il
carico. Segnale 17. abbondanza
interiore. La dipendenza affettiva non è
un comportamento.
La dipendenza affettiva è un calcolo che
il tuo sistema nervoso genera
costantemente. La domanda è: quanto
dipende da questa singola interazione
per me? Se la risposta è molto, lo
trasmetterai a prescindere da quanto sia
corretta la tua postura. Il tuo corpo
invierà segnali su mille canali che
indicano che c'è qualcosa in gioco. La
microtensione nella mascella, la mezza
esitazione prima di ogni risposta, la
domanda di approfondimento.
Quando una frase non suscita la risposta
sperata e lei non penserà, "È
appiccicoso".
Penserà semplicemente "Sento qualcosa di
stretto". Psicologia.
Lo stato che chiamiamo abbondanza non
deriva dall'avere molte opzioni, deriva
da una vita che non è vuota. Un uomo con
un lavoro stimolante, amici che lo
conoscono, un corpo che usa e una
domenica che non teme, possiede un
equilibrio diverso dentro di sé. Per lui
stasera c'è poco in gioco, non perché
sia arrogante, ma perché è già
soddisfatto altrove. La configurazione.
Questo è l'unico segnale in questo video
che non funzionerà stasera. Ci vogliono
mesi. Crea qualcosa che ti tenga
occupato quando nessuno ti guarda.
Coltiva due amicizie in cui vieni
chiamato, non solo quella che ti chiama.
Abbi una cosa nella tua settimana che
non vedi l'ora di fare e che non ha
nulla a che fare con nessuno che stai
cercando di impressionare. L'effetto,
quando la tua vita è piena, ogni singolo
incontro diventa più facile, non meno
importante, solo più facile. E questa
facilità è proprio la sensazione che lei
in seguito chiamerà attrazione. All'uomo
che non ha bisogno di nulla viene
offerto di più. Non è un'ironia del
destino, sono le statistiche. Segnale
18. Pronti a partire. Ora la situazione
si farà scomoda, quindi lo dirò
direttamente. Finché non sei pronto a
concludere una conversazione, non hai
libertà in quella conversazione. E senza
libertà non c'è attrazione, c'è solo
pubblicità. La maggior parte degli
uomini si ferma troppo a lungo.
Rimangono quando la conversazione è
ormai morta da un pezzo. Rimangono
quando si sentono a disagio. Soportano
perché andarsene sembra una resa e
perché un'interazione negativa è
comunque meglio di nessuna interazione.
Lo sente in ogni istante. La psicologia
ci dice che l'attrazione presuppone la
reale possibilità che non si verifichi.
Un'offerta che non può essere rifiutata
non è un'offerta, è un assedio. Se
potessi andartene e invece resti, il tuo
restare diventerebbe una scelta e le
scelte hanno valore. La presenza senza
un'alternativa non ne ha.
La regola: stabilisci un limite
interiore prima di andare ovunque, non
come una minaccia, ma come un atto di
rispetto per te stesso. Se una
conversazione diventa irrispettosa,
concludila educatamente. Se la serata
sta per finire, torna a casa senza
salutare, come se qualcuno chiedesse una
proroga. E la versione più difficile, se
le cose vanno bene, vai comunque per
primo, non come tattica. ma come
abitudine, determinando da te stesso il
fine, il risultato. Sentirai cambiare
completamente il tuo linguaggio del
corpo, non appena questa possibilità
diventerà realtà dentro di te. Ti
rilasserai perché non sarai più
intrappolato. I segnali da 1 a 16
appariranno quasi automaticamente.
Chi non può andarsene non può veramente
restare. Segnale 19. lo sguardo del
testimone. Ora passiamo all'altro lato
della medaglia, perché tutto ciò che
abbiamo detto finora potrebbe essere
interpretato erroneamente come distanza
e la distanza da sola non rende un uomo
attraente, lo rende solo
irraggiungibile.
Ciò che segue è il contrappeso e il
segnale più raro di tutti. La maggior
parte delle persone non ascolta,
aspetta. aspetta con una risposta già
pronta, con la propria storia, con un
consiglio e l'altra persona se ne
accorge sempre, non dal contenuto, ma
dallo sguardo che si intromette
leggermente mentre sta ancora parlando.
Psicologia. Gli esseri umani hanno un
bisogno profondo, in gran parte
insoddisfatto di essere visti, non
ammirati, non consigliati, ma visti,
ovvero che qualcuno fosse effettivamente
presente mentre parlavano. Coloro che
soddisfano questo bisogno vengono
ricordati con un'intensità
sproporzionata rispetto al tempo
trascorso insieme. l'esercizio. Quando
lei parla, rispondi non dopo, ma
immediatamente.
Smetti di pianificare la tua risposta.
Il tuo unico compito è capire cosa prova
mentre parla. E poi, invece di
rispondere a una storia fate una seconda
domanda sullo stesso argomento. Solo
una, quasi nessuno lo fa. La seconda
domanda è il momento in cui una
conversazione smette di essere uno
scambio e inizia a essere un'esperienza.
Il risultato? Lei ricorderà la
conversazione come la migliore che abbia
avuto da molto tempo e non sarà in grado
di dire cosa abbiate parlato, perché in
realtà non avete parlato quasi di
niente. Non è un trucco. Questa è la
forma più sincera di generosità che un
uomo possa possedere. L'attenzione
è l'unica moneta che acquista valore
quantomeno la si disperde. Segnale 20.
Divertimento personale, una fonte tutta
tua. Ecco il segnale finale. Quello che
ho menzionato all'inizio viene quasi
sempre trascurato. Chiediti onestamente,
quando sei in una conversazione, la
reazione di chi determina come ti senti.
Per la maggior parte degli uomini la
risposta è la sua. Dice qualcosa, la
osserva attentamente e a seconda di ciò
che vi scorge si sente bene o male. ha
ceduto il controllo del proprio stato
d'animo a una persona che conosce da 11
minuti e lei sente questo peso. Ogni
donna conosce la sensazione che la sua
reazione sia improvvisamente diventata
troppo importante per qualcuno. Non è
una sensazione piacevole, è una
responsabilità che nessuno ha chiesto.
La psicologia dell'autointrattenimento
consiste nel creare il proprio stato
d'animo. Dici cose che trovi
interessanti, ridi di ciò che ti sembra
divertente. Racconti la storia che
ancora ti affascina, non contro di essa,
ma di fronte ad essa. Se ti coinvolge,
benissimo, altrimenti la serata non è
rovinata. Il cambiamento: smetti di
testare le tue frasi per il loro
effetto, mettile alla prova per la loro
veridicità. Prima di parlare, non
chiederti. sarà ben accolto, ma lo penso
davvero. La prova è semplice e spietata.
Dille qualcosa che sei sicuro non
troverà divertente e ridici sopra
comunque il risultato: non appena il tuo
stato d'animo non dipende più dalla sua
reazione, lo squilibrio cessa. E questo
squilibrio era fin dall'inizio l'unica
cosa che si frapponeva tra te e lei. Non
il tuo aspetto, non la tua età, non il
tuo conto in banca. Un uomo che sa stare
bene con se stesso è l'unico uomo che si
vorrebbe avere accanto. Ecco perché ho
messo questo segnale alla fine. Non è il
più difficile, è quello che rende reali
tutti gli altri. Prima di concludere,
devo mettervi in guardia da tre errori.
Li riscontro in quasi tutti coloro che
utilizzano questi segnali per la prima
volta e ognuno di essi non solo annulla
l'effetto, ma lo inverte. Primo errore,
cercare di fare tutto in una volta.
Uscire di casa domani significa pensare
a 20 cose. Il risultato non è un uomo
sicuro di sé, ma un uomo che sembra stia
spuntando mentalmente una lista di cose
da fare, perché è esattamente quello che
sta facendo. Il suo sguardo si fa fisso,
i suoi movimenti artificiali, la sua
voce piatta. Hai inviato tutti e 20enti
i segnali, ma ne hai trasmesso solo uno,
la tensione. Scegline tre, solo tre.
Secondo errore, esagerare. Quasi tutti
gli uomini esagerano con questi segnali
al primo tentativo. Un secondo di
contatto visivo si trasforma in quattro.
Il 10% più lento diventa metà velocità.
Un accenno di sorriso diventa
un'espressione immobile. Ricordate
questa regola generale: ogni segnale in
questo video funziona nella dose in cui
nessuno lo nota. Non appena qualcuno lo
nota diventa una messa in scena ed è
proprio la messa in scena che vogliamo
eliminare. Terzo errore, le aspettative.
Lo metti in pratica e aspetti un
risultato. E se non arriva
immediatamente decidi che semplicemente
non fa per te. Ma ogni aspettativa è una
forma di bisogno e il bisogno è stato
l'unico nemico che abbiamo combattuto
per tutto questo video. Chiunque usi i
segnali per ottenere qualcosa, invia
automaticamente il 17º segnale nella
direzione sbagliata. Quindi usateli
perché è così che volete vivere, non
perché volete qualcosa in cambio. La
differenza potrebbe sembrare
insignificante, ma è la differenza
principale. Ci assume una postura
studiata per farsi notare, è
costantemente in attesa di una reazione
e questa attesa è evidente. Chi invece
sta in piedi dritto perché ha deciso di
farlo non aspetta nulla. Solo il secondo
approccio ha un impatto. Il risultato
arriverà da sé. Semplicemente non arriva
su richiesta. Conclusione: la tua
eredità come uomo. Signori, l'attrazione
non è una lotteria che si vince grazie a
buoni geni. L'attrazione è un insieme di
segnali e la buona notizia è puoi
controllarli. 20 segnali sono troppi per
domani. Lo so, cambiare tutto in una
volta non cambia nulla. Quindi
sceglietene tre. Suggerisco queste tre
perché sono le più rapide da adottare e
richiedono meno coraggio. La postura del
segnale 1, il rallentamento del 10% del
segnale 5 e il contatto visivo di un
secondo del segnale 2. Tre settimane,
solo queste tre. Poi prendi le prossime,
poi noterai qualcosa di inaspettato. Le
persone ti trattano in modo diverso, non
solo le donne, ma tutti. I colleghi ti
interrompono meno spesso, i venditori ti
prendono più sul serio e gli sconosciuti
si spostano di un passo quando entri in
una stanza, perché questi segnali non
sono mai stati segnali di appuntamento,
sono sempre stati segnali di status. Le
donne semplicemente li interpretano più
velocemente. Ora vorrei dire qualcosa
sulla tua età. L'età non segna la fine
della tua vitalità, bensì l'inizio della
tua era più intensa.
Tu hai esperienza, storie da raccontare
e profondità, cose che gli uomini più
giovani non hanno ancora maturato. Hai
perso qualcosa e sei sopravvissuto.
Sai cosa puoi sopportare perché l'hai
già sopportato.
un venticinquenne non può fingere di
avere tutto questo a prescindere dal suo
aspetto. La pace e la tranquillità di
cui abbiamo parlato fin dall'inizio,
sono cose che non si possono comprare né
accelerare, si possono ottenere solo
vivendo abbastanza a lungo. Possedete
già la materia prima. Questo video vi ha
semplicemente mostrato come renderla
visibile ed è per questo che l'ultima
cosa che voglio darvi non è un segnale,
ma una richiesta. Non usare questi
strumenti psicologici per fingere, ma
per aiutare il mondo a vedere l'uomo che
sei già dentro. Ci sono molti uomini che
usano tecniche per ottenere ciò che
vogliono, non essere uno di loro. Non
hai ricevuto questi 20 segnali per
persuadere qualcuno. Li hai ricevuti
affinché non ci sia più rumore tra chi
sei e ciò che ricevi. Questo è tutto ciò
che è successo qui. Abbiamo eliminato il
rumore. Ha il diritto di entrare in ogni
stanza a testa alta. Non si tratta di
ego, si tratta di dignità.
L'ego vuole che gli altri si
sminuiscano. La dignità non ne ha
bisogno. Un uomo dignitoso non toglie
nulla a nessuno quando entra in una
stanza, anzi porta qualcosa con sé. E le
donne distinguono tra questi due tipi di
uomini con molta più affidabilità di
quanta ne distinguano tra due volti. Non
hai mai avuto bisogno di un aspetto
migliore. Hai semplicemente smesso di
scusarti per quello che hai. Se hai
trovato utile questo contenuto,
iscriviti al canale. Pubblico nuovi
spunti ogni settimana per gli uomini che
sono pronti a vivere la vita che
desiderano veramente. Scrivete nei
commenti quali tre segnali avete scelto
di approfondire. Li leggerò tutti. è
nelle tue mani. Ci vediamo nel prossimo
video.